- [Voiceover] How much time has passed
from the time on the left
to the time on the right?
So, we have a clock on the
left and a clock on the right
with different times shown,
and we want to know how much
time since the clock said,
that read this first time,
'til it read the second time.
We're also told the time
passed is less than 12 hours.
That's helpful.
That means we know that
this first clock wasn't
say some time on Monday
and the second was sometime on Wednesday,
and these hands have been
going around and around.
We know that time passed
is less than 12 hours.
So, the first thing I think we should do
to find out the difference in these times
is to figure out what are these times.
Let's read these clocks.
Over here on the left,
looking at our hour hand first,
it's between six and seven.
So, the hour hand starts at the top
and it's gone passed six o'clock,
but it's not quite to seven.
So, it's six something.
Could be six fifteen, six twenty,
we'll figure out the minutes next.
But we know it's some
amount of minutes after six,
but not yet seven.
And now let's look at those minutes.
The minute hand, again started at the top,
and it's gone five minutes,
10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40.
Can't go to 45 here, so
we've got to count by ones.
41, 42, 43!
It is 43 minutes after six
o'clock, or 6:43 on the left.
On the right, our hour hand
is just after the nine,
so it's soon after nine o'clock,
but it's definitely not to 10 yet.
And then our minute hand, right here.
Start at the top
and it's five, 10, 11
minutes after the hour.
On the right.
So, the clock on the right is 9:11.
And now what we want to know
is how long does it take
to get from this first time, 6:43,
all the way to the second
time, which is 9:11.
One way we could figure
this out is to break it
into little parts.
Let's first, let's first just see
how long does it take
to get to seven o'clock?
So, in this first clock
as soon as the minute hand
gets up to the top it'll be seven o'clock.
Let's see how long is that.
From here where it is,
it has two more minutes
to get to the nine.
And then from there it has
five, 10, 15 more minutes
to get all the way to
the top of the clock.
So, until seven o'clock
it'll be two minutes
plus 15 more minutes,
or we can write that as 17 minutes.
Then from seven,
let's stick with the hours for a second.
Let's just get from seven to nine o'clock.
So, from seven to nine.
At seven o'clock the hand is at the top,
it'll go all the way around one hour
to be eight o'clock.
All the way another
hour to be nine o'clock.
So that's a total, from seven to nine,
of two hours.
And then finally from nine
to 11 minutes after nine.
The minute hand will be at the top
and it'll go five, 10, 11 minutes.
So, this will be 11 more minutes.
So, in total,
from 6:43 all the way to 9:11
is 17 minutes, plus two
more hours, plus 11 minutes.
So, we could write that,
that's going to be two hours,
and then we can combine
our minutes, 17 and 11.
17 and 11.
That'll be eight ones,
a 10 and a 10 is 20.
So, 28 minutes.
It takes two hours and 28
minutes for the clock to go
from 6:43, this time on the left,
until 9:11, the time on the right.